This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Audible.
What's the difference between a MOVIE PIRATE
and a MUSIC PIRATE?
Booty.
Lots and lots of booty.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
Until this week, I've kiiiind of lumped pirates
of all kinds into one category.
Well, maybe with the exception of separating
pirates at sea from pirates at a computer....little
less violent, yaknow?
This week, a new study published in the Journal
of Behavioral and Experimental Economics found
that there ARE actually some significant differences
between the group of people that pirate mostly
movies and the people that pirate mostly music.
The biggest difference is that movie pirates
still spend a lot of cashola on the *legal*
enjoyment of movies.
Not so much the case for music pirates.
Those who pirate movies are also, on average:
wealthier, more likely to live in a city,
more willing to cut down the piracy if they
believe it's hurting the industry, AND are
also are less likely to believe they'll get
caught than music pirates.
Why the divide between the two groups?
The scientists believe it forms out of the
technological demand of illegally downloading
movies.
As in: it's a little harder to do.
You have to figure out how to torrent, you
have to know how to play it back, and then
there's also the issue of storing lots of
large files.
They believe this is why movie pirates tend
to be a little more technologically savvy
than music pirates.
The fact that movie pirates spend more money
on legal content shouldn't come as a huuuuge
surprise.
Several studies have found that people who
pirate spend more money on media than people
who purchase everything legally -- about 30%
more in fact.
The idea is that pirates are just bigger consumers
of media, period.
So, what could this meannnnn?
Well, for one it busts the myth that pirates
are just people who don't want to pay for
things.
They do pay for things, especially movie pirates,
just not EVERYTHING.
A few other thoughts: the fact that movie
pirates still buy *so much legal content*
and *are willing to cut back* suggests that
CONVENIENCE might play a role in pirating.
It's there, readily available, while the legal
alternative isn't.
Maybe it's not available legally online, maybe
it's only available in another country, maybe
you have to drive to go pick it up and rent
it -- and when you're there, sitting on your
couch, the hassle (or impossibility) of those
legal alternatives just aren't persuasive
enough.
Another possible implication is that some
movie pirating happens when people feel ripped
off.
Like that one time I tried to rent The Hobbit
when it first came out on iTunes and it cost
something like $15 for 1 play and 24 hours.
Or, for instance, if the pirate believes there's
a good chance the movie will be terrible and
doesn't want to fork over 14 bucks to see
a crappy movie.
It's not that they don't HAVE the money, it's
that they don't feel like it's WORTH the money.
SO!
What do YOU FOLKS make of this study?
Why might pirates buy more content?
And for those of you interested in legal content
AND helping out the show, you can get a free
audiobook at audiblepodcast.com/dnews.
Awwwww yeah, get your Hobbit fix thataway.
Thanks for joining me, I'll cya next time.